What I want to do in
this video is really
think about what happens
when we define a function,
and actually what happens as
we step through the program
and we use the function.
So let's say we
write this program,
just like we did in the
last video, and we run it.
So the interpreter will start
at this first line over here.
It says, oh look, there's
a function definition.
We're defining the
function factorial.
What I'm going to do here is
I'm going to make a big box.
And this big box
is the environment.
And an environment
for a program is
all of the different
definitions,
and variable definitions,
and everything
that are specific to the context
that the program is running in.
So immediately, the program will
associate the name factorial
with this whole function
right over here.
So right when it says
define factorial,
it'll actually associate
factorial-- the label
factorial, you could say it--
it'll associate the label
factorial with a function that
looks like all of this business
right over here.
So you'll pass it a number.
And I'm not using-- well,
maybe I'll write it like this.
It's a function.
And I'm not using the-- you'll
see different notations, lambda
notation and all
of this fancy stuff
if you take a formal
computer science class.
But all I'm just saying
is factorial refers
to a function that has
the parameters-- that
only has one parameter.
It has the parameter number.
And then given this function
with the parameter number,
it'll then process this code.
So let me just copy and
paste it right here.
And then-- whoops-- I'm
doing it in the wrong layer.
Let me copy and paste it again.
So let me try to copy it.
Let me copy it.
And then let me paste it.
So that's what it's
doing right over there.
And actually, I
should make this box.
The environment
includes all of this.
I think you'll bear with me.
I didn't draw this orange
box big enough the first time
around.
So let me do that just so
that no one gets confused.
Just so that no
one gets confused,
let me expand the orange box.
And I erased a little bit.
One of the parameters is number.
And then that orange box
goes around the whole thing.
That's a green color.
All right, here we go.
So right when we hit this
first few lines, it's saying,
look, in our entire
global environment,
we're defining a function.
The factorial will now
refer to a function
that takes the parameter number.
And then it'll run all of this
code that we've defined here.
And then it'll return whatever
inside this function world,
whatever the value of
the variable product is.
And then it keeps going
line by line by line.
And then we get to this
line right over here.
And it says, the variable
user input is equal to--
and then it calls
the function input.
And it passes the
function input.
And I'm starting to use a
little bit of the terminology
that we've been exposed to.
It passes the function
input a string.
So this right here is a string.
And once again, string
sounds like a fancy word.
But it literally means
string of characters,
or this text right
here, the text
enter a non-negative
integer to take
the factorial of colon space.
So even the spaces are
part of the strings.
And the telltale
sign for a string
is it's going to be inside
some type of quotation marks,
either double or
single quotation marks.
So by passing this to
that input function,
that tells the input function
what to prompt the user.
So it prompts the
user with this string.
The user types in a number
or some type of expression.
That gets evaluated, and then
gets stored in user input.
Or I really should say, in
then the Python context,
user input refers to that value.
So let's say the user inputs 3.
Then the variable
user input will
refer, in this
global environment--
now factorial refers to
a function-- user input
refers to whatever
the user typed in.
I'm going to go with the
specific example of 3.
Then we go to the next line.
And it's saying, look, make
factorial of user input.
Make this entire variable
refer to whatever
we get when we call factorial
of user input, factorial
of this variable over here.
And so this is the
interesting part.
At this point in the program,
the factorial of user input,
this part right over here, it
makes a call to this function.
It makes a call
to this function.
And it gives it the argument
of whatever user input is.
Now, user input
is referring to 3.
So it is going to pass 3
to the function factorial.
So 3 gets passed here.
And essentially, within
this function world--
so now let's say that this
is the context of running
this function-- so within
this function world--
let me make it clear.
So now, within this
function world right
over here, the
function's environment,
the variable number within this
function world now refers to 3.
I now want to be a
little bit careful,
because we're starting to
touch on the idea of scope
of a variable.
The variable number in
this function world,
it is only referenceable
within the function.
And we do refer it
It is not a referable
outside of the function.
So if down here
someplace, I were
to say print number,
you would get an error,
because it would be out of
the scope of that variable.
This variable, it's a
parameter to this function.
It's only usable
within this function.
Its scope, the place
where you can refer to it,
is only in this function.
So you get that number.
And then it does the code
that we've looked at before.
It sets the variable product.
So the variable product
now refers to the number 1.
Then it calls all of this code.
And since we've
talked about scope,
I'll talk about another
situation of scope.
This variable i is only
valid within the scope
of the for loop.
If down here I said return i,
that would have given an error.
You can only refer to
it within the for loop.
And we've gone through
this code multiple times.
It goes from i equals 0 to
i equals 1 to i equals 2,
all the way up to i is equal
to 1 less than the number.
But since we're adding
1 to i every time,
it's really going from--
this whole expression
right over here starts at 1,
then 2, then 3, all the way up
to the number.
And each time, we're multiplying
it times the original product
to get a new product.
So at the end of
the day, after we
go through this whole
for loop, product
will contain the
factorial of the number.
So after you do
this, product will
keep referring to
a bunch of things.
It'll refer to 1.
Then it'll refer to 2.
Then it'll refer to 6, because
we're going to do 3 times 2.
So eventually, product
is going to refer to 6.
And that is returned.
And when I say that
that is returned,
that means when you evaluate
this entire thing over here,
that entire thing
is going to be 6.
And then once we get
out of that program,
it let's the interpreter know
that factorial of user input
should now refer to that 6.
I know this might be a
little bit confusing with all
of this diagramming.
But I really want you to get
the sense of what's happening.
User input is
referring to something.
We pass that something
to the factorial program.
So then we go up here.
And within the
factorial program,
now, since we've passed
user input and user
input was 3, within
the factorial program,
this number is
going to refer to 3.
And then we run this
as if number was 3.
And then we return
product, which
is going to be the
factorial of number.
And so this whole
thing evaluates
to the factorial of whatever was
in here, so the factorial of 3.
And so factorial of user
input, this variable,
will now refer to that, because
it's being assigned to that.
And then we print it.
And when we print
it, that's what
actually shows up down
in our interpreter.
So hopefully that doesn't
confuse you too much.
In the next video,
we'll discuss how
we might be able to
do interesting things
to this function itself.